Where we're at now.
I mean,
I expect sometime next week
to get an announcement this,
this bill should have been passed and
brought into the house a long time ago.
And, uh, you know, not the
case still. Dot. Still stalled
and everything. And again,
it's all lobbying,
illegal lobbying,
which may or may not turn into some,
uh,
problems for Senator Don Plett. Correct
me if I'm wrong, but for a while,
some of the,
some of the parks in the United States
would get them from some of the parks and
Canada,
which would get them from Russians and
Chinese who would capture them in the
wild. Right? So, so the parks,
the United States would say
that they don't capture whales.
So what they would do is marine la
would capture a boatload of wild ones.
And then once, uh, uh,
they would do it personally while
they would pay some Russians to,
to capture the elections that they always
use. Oh God. Damn. Russians. Oh Man,
I'm not going to cheat at the Olympics.
They're stealing whales.
So they bring the whales in wild. Those
wa those, those whales have. For instance,
uh, you know, they Syrah calf,
that calf is now deemed a captive born
and now it can be shipped to the states.
And so it,
so what marine land was doing was just
breeding like crazy and in sending them
to seaworld and that's how we got the,
the killer whale to begin with.
How we got I Kaikos you know,
big trade with Belugas and,
and so that's what we're trying to put
an end to because all these loopholes,
you know,
Marineland really capitalized on this,
but they want a long time
lobbying the government for years.
I mean they've been around for 50
plus years. They've had, they've,
they've done all the right moves a
businessman would do if he wants to keep a
thriving business without too many
hands sort of keeping them from doing
anything.
It's just so disturbing that we're willing
to just accept this because we don't
know what they're saying.
You know,
we know that they have a
really complex language.
We can't decipher it though because it's
so alien in terms of like the sounds
that they make.
It's not something we put into a box,
but it's not like any other animal,
but you in dolphins and killer
whales and Wales in general,
they make sounds in it with a range
of complexity that's just unrivaled in
nature outside of humans.
And their auditory system is so complex.
When you put them in a, we put them in a
concrete pool. Just imagine what I mean.
I, I put my ears under the water and
it's loud. The filters are going,
you've got different
sounds. I mean, right.
Water being pushed in from this pipe and
that scream and people screaming music
louder. Louder, louder. Popcorn.
The audience figures. Yeah.
God Damn. It's a, I mean, I, I look
at them almost like they're kind of,
I mean, they're definitely not
human, but they're kind of people.
They like a water people.
It's weird. If you,
if you put yourself in the mindset of
looking at an animal and you're trying to
change your perception of
them a little bit rather than,
than sort of disassociating and
you'd look at him, you, you stuck,
you can actually see that. They're
like, oh, it's like they're people, man.
Like that's, that's just a
different meat suit. Yeah, like,
and then you deal with killer
whales and stuff. I mean, well,
they evolved in a different environment,
but they evolve to be incredibly social,
a highly dynamic populations.
They,
they live in these very intimate groups.
They stay together for life.
A male killer whale, we'll never leave.
It's mother's side over its lifetime.
It'll stay within about a body's.
It's entire life. Unless the pause,
there's beating on it,
then I'll just stay out on the
outside of the pod for awhile.
At least they have that luxury
of escape where in captivity,
males get the shit kicked
out of them. They're a big
puppy dogs, big male. Orchids,
I mean, yeah. Okay. They're
murderous and they're killing people,
but they're actually big puppy dogs.
They're there.
I always felt so bad for candy. We had
this big male, beautiful, big bull male.
He was just, he was rocked his existence.
I having been pulled from his mother,
and this is really largely explains
why went off. You ruined their lives.
That's over. I mean their whole 30 on
diets, the reason they live, remember too,
they remember going a month that fuck man,
it's just why do we allow this?
It seems to me like, like almost
a form of slavery. I mean,
I don't want to diminish the horrors of
human slavery because in human slavery
at least there's no question whatsoever
that that's a human and there's
communication. Yeah. So it's,
it's as awful as it gets.
But God damn put the ignorance aside.
The slavery of killer whales is like
really close. It's really close.
The only way to get them
to work effectively and
efficiently is to keep them
hungry. Oh, drug them
and keep them hungry.
So yeah, it's brutal. Now is it
still legal? I mean, isn't, see,
he's since seaworld. Are they expanding?
Didn't they just make a bigger,
a pool for the silhouettes?
Like, well, we're slow.
We're so nice to her killer whales.
We gave him a bigger k. Yeah.
So what they've done is they've tried to
repackage the show as we were not doing
the big dynamic show, but they
really still are. They're like,
we're just showing natural behaviors.
Which is bitch natural behavior.
Let them go fuck up a whale. Shit.
They put a fuck. They put like a,
like a backdrop of a couple trees
assumption, new show. Hey, see,
well this is what other crazy shit going
on. I mean in, in a, in California,
see world now see where promise
to stop banning. Uh, uh, they,
they promised to stop
breathing the killer whales.
But these fucking promises don't do not
believe for a moment that they're like
some type of responsible
corporate citizens. It's
gonna hold on to this thing.
It's bullshit. So we're an
entity, a business entity.
They're trying to make money.
And so what California did was
they went out and banned it.
So in California you can't breed Orkos.
I import export issues, all that,
but in Florida. So again,
see what makes the promise.
They had an Orca protection act that they
were looking to do exactly. California.
We're going to put it,
they were going to make it concrete
passed the law that way that we see world
can't just backpedal on it down the road,
which everyone suspects they will see
where this lobbying like fucking crazy and
just just last week says
successfully defeated the bill again,
they're putting a lot of the world
is trying to defeat a bill that they
successfully defeated multiple times,
including that just last week that allows
them or be the bill would keep them
from breeding these animals in captivity.
You're fighting against that
successfully fighting. It's over.
They're doing it in Florida. Yeah.
While they're pretending in California,
they don't want to breed
them. Well, no. In California,
they actually passed the law,
the State Law in Florida.
It was defeated repeatedly and now
fun last down. So they're trying,
they're trying to breed animals in
captivity and if they do breed them in
Florida, there'll be able to ship
them to California, to China.
So that's what the demand is right now.
And in fact,
seaworld was just bought by a large
Chinese corporation they just named.
They just named one of the,
one of the guys to the seaworld board.
And so what people,
I mean it's safe to assume that this
is exactly what's happening is zero.
This is planning their exit strategy
and they're gonna start sending their,
their orcas to, to China. Oh Geez. That's
a booming industry right now. In fact,
killer whale captivity is like,
if you can get your and there and it's all
coming out of Russia, right still. But,
and so there's still capturing them in
the wild. Yup. And in China it's, it's a,
it's a burgeoning,
a booming industry man.
44 [inaudible] lotion,
theme parks in China right now.
She is building a black crazy.
How many of them are in the United States?
How many aquariums? Yeah, I don't know.
I can't, I can't say for sure. Ah,
I was actually surprised to read
there's like 300 something dolphins in
captivity in the states. I didn't,
I think that was the number I saw.
I didn't realize there was that big.
I had no idea that there was that
many in captivity in the states.
It just seems to be such an
archaic thing that it just,
I can't imagine that the United
States wants to keep doing that.
The fact that seaworld is trying to keep
doing that in Florida and that they've
successfully lobbied to allow them to
keep breeding these animals in captivity.
But you can't, once you have them
in captivity for a long time,
safe seaworld wanted to release them.
They can't really release them.
There's nowhere to release them.
And that's what's being worked on now.
There's a project called the
whale sanctuary project and I,
I suspect there'll be a fairly
large announcement soon.
I believe there'll be
looking at a location and in
Canada and they're going to
build this thing though there
will be a place for them,
which is a great place to do it
because then how would they do that?
Well you go coastal of course.
I mean you gotta be in the ocean and you
got a pen off an area. You've got to,
I mean there's lots of things to consider.
You've got to make sure
there's a lot of water changes.
So a lot of different things.
Cause you can't keep the animal and
something that's going to stagnate the
minute. So it's going to be
some sort of a cage it, yeah.
I'm assume a fence of sorts around there.
Maybe like a fjord.
I wouldn't be a fjord if it's in Canada,
but like just imagine jump it.
I imagine that they'll make certain that
that's not going to be the case. But uh,
while they can, I've seen,
I've seen dolphins jump out
of the pool. That's crazy.
Really? Yeah. Yeah. I got rushed in one
morning to, uh, uh, called him because uh,
because a dolphin jumped out of the pool.
Holy Shit.
I mean that's a wake up call when you
get there and you see this thing flopping
around and you're like,
Jesus Christ and I didn't do well.
You get the sling together.
First off, there's, you know,
we have these different slings and things
that, you know, to move these dolphins.
So I was, I was alone. I was a dolphin
way. Yeah. Like 500 pounds, 600 pounds.
In this case she was,
she was a decent size female.
So I went and grabbed a kid out in
the ticket booth. There's some shifts.
It was too early in the morning. I had no
staff there. Russia men. I'm like, dude,
I got two guys. I'm like, we gotta get
this dolphin and these guys. I mean,
if you've never done that before,
your jaws on the floor.
I fucking had these two steel poles
on my shoulders. Dolphin in the sling,
lifting her up. I swear to you, man,
my back went backwards like this.
It was the heaviest thing
I'd ever carried, but we got
her back in. It was crazy.
But yeah, jumped out of the
pool. It was crazy. In fact,
there was a time in the summer,
I remember where one of our
dolphins were teetering on the edge,
which you would do, is she,
you know, they're, they're
always spy hop and like this,
looking over the edge of the crowd,
explaining that to people that are
just listening, just listening.
So imagine there's like a short wall,
something that they can look over.
So there's sort of spy hop in
there, spying up to look. Okay.
One of our dolphins learned that she
can actually jump up on the ledge and
balance.
Now she was on that.
That's like an eight foot drop to the
concrete and the other side of the school.
She's up there posing. I'm
hearing the crowd, I'm backstage.
I hear the crowd going crazy. I'm
like, what is this? I go with her.
She's having fun doing this.
Holy Shit.
That's the dolphin that jumped
out as what we did with,
I said we got to take her out
of this pool. We took her out,
put her in the back pool where
no one would see her of course.
And that's the next day
she actually jumped.
So she'd be dead today if
we hadn't of moved her. Oh.
Then of course all Marineland did
was put up like more, you know,
more obstruction, things to
keep, keep me in the pool.
So now when you find her outside of the
pool, how long had she been outside for?
She was still wet, so it wasn't so
bad. But one, uh, one dolphin was,
we found her that she, she, she
got stuck on the stage overnight.
And when we got there,
her skin had become so dry that it was,
it was starting to crack.
It was kind of fucked up.
She actually has this permanent
scar from try not to yeah.
And a chunk come out when, I don't
know what she was probably thrashed.
Are you talking to her when you find
there? Do you try to comfort her? Like,
I mean, yeah, sure. I'm hugging her
and everything else. Let's say she,
did she calm down when she realizes
that people were trying to help her?
Like are they aware of what's going on
or she in a panic, they always fight.
They always fight if they don't want to.
I mean this particular
dolphin was a fighter.
Every time we ever tried to put
her in a sling. And we were,
I mean one time I love,
I could go back in memories and I can,
I can remember my thoughts
during these times. And uh,
we had her in a sling
hovering over the pool.
And the way the sling is is you've got
two holes in the sling where the pex go
in, right, the pectoral fins. And
then one where the genital slit is.
So if they shit, it doesn't end up
stuck in the, in the sling, but,
and then you've got a crane,
a top.
So now you've got this thing
lifted over the pool. Well,
she's fighting like crazy and we can
see that there's a tear in the sling as
she's fighting, fighting,
fighting. We'd get her,
the crane just gets rid of the pool to
sling rip. She's plunked into the pool.
Holy Shit Man.
And we've,
we've slimmed out like 15,000 pound or
10,000 pound killer whales over like 30
40 feet in the air. Imagine one
of those five drops. Oh my God.
So that was sort of a wake
up call. Wow. Yeah. Archaic
procedures, man. Moving these,
these things. The things that,
especially at a place like marine land,
Marine Marineland when you step through
the doors and hopefully you don't,
but if you do, it's like you've
gone back to the 70s the jazz,
any of this hurt their business.
Attendance is abysmal over there.
They're crushed. I live right.
I S I watched the sunset over
marine land from my front yard.
It's a beautiful site.
I drive by, of course,
just about every day that their
attendance is rocked and Niagara Falls,
which where it is, where
marine land is, is booming.
The tourism is through the roof.
You can't,
it's shoulder to shoulder over there
and Murraylands seeing none of it.
And you think it's because people know
about the conditions of, absolutely.
I've got a lot of support
in the local community.
Like people know exactly what's going on.
A tourist,
it's a little more difficult than, you
know, Nag falls welcomes millions of them,
so you're going to get a fraction of that,
but it is a fraction.
Murraylands not benefiting
from the booming tourism there.
They're on their way out the, they're
on a clock for sure. For sure.
I'd be shocked to hear them opening
in 2019 I'm not going to make that
prediction, but I would be shocked.
It's, it's that bad. But to be fair,
there's no investors at Marineland.
It's one sole controlling mine
owner who started with nothing.
He started with 2000 bucks, built this
thing. He is indebted to nobody. He's,
you know, his cash rich. Of course,
and he's got a lot of fuck you
money and not a lot of times.
So he's out to fuck shit up.
I wouldn't be surprised to know.
And a lot of time in life. You
mean like 84 years old now?
Yeah. And so, uh, I would,
I wouldn't be surprised to think that
he's rationalized in his mind to just
fucking sewer this thing like destroy,
destroy all our lives.
We're having spoken out but just tank the
park in the process. Fucking wow. Yeah.
He's very defined. He's a, he's a, he's
a very paranoid and defiant men. And so,
you know, at 84 years old, what else
does he have left to accomplish?
I guess so you were saying
that 50 Beluga whales,
B plus maybe even 60 at this point,
Beluga whales are huge. Yeah.
What is a big one way?
I don't know if we've ever met,
if we ever actually weighed our big
magnetic yes. At 4,000 pounds, maybe five.
You got 50 of those. 50 of them. Yeah.
That's insane. Try Catching one. Oh,
I don't want to try it. I used
to get tasked with, here's your,
here's your scuba gear,
here's a,
a net the size of a football field called
catch that Beluga whale is that me and
my buddies would be like, okay, here
we go. Oh Dude, you'd be, you'd be,
it really would be amazing to be able to
capture the things we've done on video.
Can you recognize the difference
in intelligence between
killer whales, dolphins,
Beluga whales, dolphins, dolphins, and
killer whales are like remarkably similar.
Just cunning. Smart. You could turn
your back and they're pickpocketing you.
I mean they are just,
and they're brats and I love brats.
I mean they just are bratty animal.
They're having fun. They're having,
while they're fucking with you,
they would like to make things difficult.
If they know, if they know
how to frustrate you, they're
going to exercise that.
So it's always a mental game, especially
with when you're dealing with animals,
training with analysts, a Beluga whales
are really timid. So like, you know,
they call him the canaries of the
seat, cause it kind of skittish. So,
I don't know if that's a reflection
of their intelligence necessarily,
but I would call them like maybe,
uh, uh, maybe a hint more dumb,
dumb than then the next
one. Right. But, you know,
they're more scared shitless of
either not, you know, by Lucas.
They don't really want it.
They don't want to be,
but they're not as smart as dolphins
or not. I wouldn't say so. I mean,
they split their internal Raga me
some way, some way intelligent. Yeah.
Yeah.